[Música]
soy 'fan' que esta manzana tiene un tlc
los nutrientes que las manzanas que
comían hace 35 años pues esto es una
consecuencia de la forma como hemos
venido produciendo los alimentos y que a
su vez incluye un problema aún más
grande y es que los suelos se están
degradando que la tierra está perdiendo
su fertilidad
en un estudio el banco mundial informó
que el 33 por ciento de la tierra el
planeta se encontraba moderadamente
grada
y esto
a su vez nos preguntamos por qué es que
corre todo esto que le hicimos a la
tierra entonces para ponerlos en
contexto entre 1960 y 1980 la humanidad
se enfrentaba a grandes retos uno de
estos retos era erradicar el hambre y la
desnutrición junto con la química se
desarrollaron diferentes tecnologías
como fertilizantes plaguicidas
herbicidas y una serie de otras
prácticas agrícolas que nos llevaron a
incrementar exponencialmente el
rendimiento de los cultivos un ejemplo
de éxito de esto es el cultivo del maíz
hace 50 años producíamos 2 toneladas de
maíz por hectárea hoy en la actualidad
llegamos a producir cerca de 15
toneladas por hectárea
esto significa 7.5 veces más alimento
producido en el mismo espacio de tierra
y si bien todo esto es muy positivo todo
esto también escondía consecuencias
negativas para el medio ambiente y
especial para el suelo
para poder producir más alimentos
comenzamos a utilizar de manera masiva y
desmedida fertilizantes y plaguicidas
todo esto llevó a generar estragos en el
medio ambiente a diferentes niveles por
un lado que los plaguicidas y pesticidas
que son venenos comenzaban a eliminar a
todo aquello que enfermaba los cultivos
como las plagas pero también eliminaron
los elementos buenos como organismos
vivos microorganismos e insectos que
éstos a su vez se encargaban de mantener
la salud de los suelos y de la tierra y
las plantas yo les cuento todo eso
porque desde hace cuatro años que vengo
trabajando en comprender los diferentes
problemas asociados a la degradación de
los suelos en la agricultura para mí
este tema de los microorganismos y las
interacciones es realmente apasionante
yo les quiero compartir un poco cómo es
que descubrí realmente este mundo tan
fascinante las interacciones y que
tienen un valor fundamental en entender
el desarrollo de los ecosistemas en las
interacciones microbianas y el
desarrollo de las plantas y cómo
funcionan los suelos una clase de
microbiología
universidad donde desarrollamos
experimentos con hongos cuya finalidad
era entender el crecimiento y desarrollo
a nivel de laboratorio era conectar
muestra del suelo de diferentes cultivos
maíz uva cítricos pallarés y otros con
esta mezcla como estados cantidad de
suelos las mezclamos con un poco de agua
destilada y luego las vertimos unas
pequeñas plaquitas que contenían un gel
de nutrientes
algo así como una gelatina entonces
esperábamos que pasaran los días y
comenzará a crecer pequeñas colonias de
microorganismos algunos serán hongos y
otras bacterias conforme iban pasando
los días y las horas estas bacterias y
hongos comenzaron a cambiar de forma
algunas comenzaron a presentar formas
rugosas otras muy lisas entonces entre
todos estos comenzó a crecer un micro el
mismo que me llamó especialmente la
atención había un hongo que no sólo
crecía mucho más rápido que el resto
sino que en ese proceso de cambio
comenzaron a aparecer las formas
unos pequeños anillos concéntricos con
diferentes formas y colores
realmente me quedé impresionado para mí
y no había visto algo similar hasta ese
entonces y se está dando cuenta que me
estaba enamorando de un hongo fue la
primera vez que me había dado cuenta que
me había enamorado de ese maravilloso
hongo entonces necesitaba conocer un
poco más de ese hongo y lo que decidí
fue aislarlo durante este proceso de
aislarlo espera un par de días para
lograr ver la misma transformación
en este punto
conforme pasaban las horas comenzó a
crecer un hongo gris sin colores y sin
anillos yo pensé que me había equivocado
entonces decidí repetir el proceso una y
otra vez hasta que me di cuenta de algo
muy importante y es que literalmente
había aislado el hongo de los otros
microorganismos entonces decidí hacer
crecer este hongo frente a los otros
mecanismos del primer experimento
pasaron los días y pasó algo realmente
fascinante allí ocurre la magia natural
y resultaba que este hongo se
transformaba en presencia de otras
bacterias esto significaba que existían
microrganismos que podrían influir en su
crecimiento y desarrollo eso para mí fue
una revelación
y siento muchos cuestionamientos en mi
vida así como existían hongos o
mecanismos que pueden influir el
crecimiento de otros podrían existir
microorganismos que puedan influenciar
el crecimiento de las plantas para hacer
que éstas tengan un mayor valor
nutricional en los alimentos esta
pregunta me rondó durante muchos años en
mi vida y lo que tocó fue comenzar a
buscar centros de investigación en donde
caló colaborar comencé a trabajar aquí
en perú y en brasil con la finalidad
entender a mayor profundidad estas
interacciones microbianas
en ese proceso de haber aprendido tanto
necesitaba experimentar y en el 2016
creó una startup llamada cova cuya
edición es regenera los suelos para toda
la humanidad creando tecnología
biológica durante los dos primeros años
junto a mi equipo comenzamos a trabajar
con diferentes tipos de microorganismos
el objetivo era entender las mejores
interacciones y en el camino nos dimos
cuenta que cada microorganismo podría
tener un beneficio muy puntual sobre las
plantas eso significaba que podrían ser
muchos productos infinitas tecnologías
para las plantas a partir de las mejores
interacciones entre todos estos logramos
desarrollar cuatro tecnologías
biológicas 410 simulantes estos 4 y
estimulantes permitían fortalecer el
crecimiento de las plantas y los
habíamos dado cuenta algo muy importante
y es que no solamente fortalece
fortalecían a las plantas sino que
también ayudaban a regenerar la
fertilidad de los suelos para nuestra
sorpresa los de estimulantes que
fortalecen el crecimiento de las plantas
y existían en países desarrollados
pero lo que no existía eran
bioestimulantes diseñados para regenerar
la fertilidad biológica de los suelos
en ese punto lo que hicimos fue tratar
de profundizar aún más en cada momento
que teníamos estas dudas de entender
cómo funciona la microbiología del suelo
comenzamos a tratar de estudiarlas cómo
funcionan las poblaciones a nivel del
suelo durante el tiempo y nos dimos
cuenta de algo las poblaciones
comenzaron a crecer y morir crecer y
morir este proceso funcionaba bajo un
principio de dinamismo natural lo que
significa que este proceso reiterativo
en que crecen y mueren ocurre
constantemente en absolutamente todos
los ecosistemas y si queríamos
desarrollar una tecnología que realmente
pueda revolucionar utilizamos los bio
estimulantes
bajo este principio de dinamismo natural
y en este momento habíamos creado un
sistema de interacciones biológicas que
no sólo podía potenciar el beneficio las
bacterias sino también las del suelo y
la de las plantas en ese momento
habíamos creado un sistema biológico de
interacciones al que llamé sistema
biodinámico este sistema no solamente
está enfocado
y mejorar el crecimiento de las plantas
sino que también está diseñado
exclusivamente en que a partir de las
interacciones lograr potenciar la
fertilidad del suelo con esto lo que
decidimos fue comenzar a validar en
diferentes cultivos
trabajamos en espárragos en fallar es
insistir cosa en falta y en cuba y si
nos dimos cuenta lo importante logramos
mejorar los rendimientos y su calidad
logramos producir alimentos más
saludables evitando una gran producción
un gran uso de pesticidas esto llevó a
que no se perdieran el valor nutricional
de estos alimentos
para este momento necesitaba buscar un
socio con quien pueda potenciar este
nuevo concepto de hacer tecnologías y
tal cual como el hongo se transformó y
covap se transformó al encontrar a mi
socio actual vasco con quien estamos
trabajando para hacer que esta
tecnología realmente pueda ser para
todos los agricultores y decirle algo
más en este momento nuestra visión
creció globalmente de desarrollar
tecnologías para la agricultura en el
perú
regenerar los suelos para toda la
humanidad y con esto evitar que los
alimentos pierdan su valor nutricional y
hacer que esta manzana que tiene un
tercero nutrientes de hace 35 años
vuelvan a tener un verdadero valor
nutricional gracias